it's the Oscars it is how you jump on
you nervous a little bit nervous it's a
little bit nervous yeah so it's a lot of
people are doing a double double segment
to we're going to be up here a bit too
and we're doing makeup and we're doing
costumes you know whole tight uh-huh
don't worry I got you I'm going to set
you up you're going to spike it your
paleness I got it
please do makeup is the art of ending an
argument Oh
when you are about to get a divorce and
then you don't that is the power of
makeup not it I got this here are this
year's nominees for achievement and
makeup and hair styling a man called
Ethan Ava fun bar and Luba Larsen Star
Trek beyond Joel Harlow and Richard
Alonzo
Suicide Squad alessandro bertolucci
Giorgio gregorini and Christopher Nelson
and the Oscar goes to for Suicide Squad
Alice and Roberta Lottie Giorgio
gregorini and Christopher Nelson this is
the first Oscar nomination for
Alessandro burger Rafi Giorgio gregorini
and Christopher Nelson
[Applause]
[Music]
you wanna talk yeah Thank You Sofia I
want to talk I have to told that waiting
for fifty years of talking probably a
bit more so by the way Thank You Academy
for making this all possible Academy is
not support is not just Oscars it's
everything support the movie support
beautiful people of course
thank you very much of the my great team
thank you to Martha I think of course my
lovely wife Giovanna he supported me for
all my life and my son followed my knee
and we cannot say thank you very much is
that the end the last thing is this for
I'm an immigrant I come from Italy I
walk around the world and this is for
all the immigrants for the amiga thank
you everybody thank you David Ayer thank
you Greg Nicotero can be Shawn's anthem
everybody please thank you so much thank
you so much if you hold of you I'm so
happy for this one and I wanna dedicate
this war to my wife that she passed away
she cannot be with me no but thank you
so much for everybody
it will jebadiah
[Applause]